how we actually become happy and
fulfilled with our lives I would split
happiness into excitement and
fulfillment when you're excited that's
happy and you can get that by going on a
roller coaster and that's happy like
doing some kind of momentary thing that
does bring you some moment of happiness
but it's the Fulfillment that is a
sustained long-term happiness and
fulfillment comes from feeling like the
work you're doing means something to
somebody else we we are wired to serve
others we want to serve the world we
have big missions we want to have a big
impact but if you woke up every day and
felt like this might matter like what
I'm doing today might matter to somebody
whether it's a big thing like making a
video I'm going to come on the growth
lab and we're going to inspire millions
of people amazing and so it's not enough
to do something for yourself when you
can tie it to this is going to help
somebody else out you have so much more
power and motivation and I think that's
what leads to long-term happiness
through fulfillment need motivation why
your top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
s Carl Michael and I make these videos
because I want to wake up and feel like
today is going to matter that I can do
something special and the way that I get
that feeling is I see people who are
doing amazing things and in watching
them say amazing things and do amazing
things it makes me feel like I can do
amazing things too so I hope that this
video helps you feel like you can do
something amazing today as well so today
you get to learn from me and my team's
take on my top 10 rules of success
enjoy rule number two is live by your
values ultimately if you think about
your most important core value let's say
it was dream then the greatest gift that
you can bring other people is to allow
them to dream as well the greatest gift
I can give people is belief and it's Al
also the thing that we need the most
help with ourselves to The Next Step so
my next step is on the other side of
even more belief yes your next step is
on the on the other side of an even
bigger
dream and so so the greatest
contribution that we can give people is
our values and that's your brand
so it may be worth spending a little bit
of of time thinking about it or go
through the exercises in the book just
figure out is it dream is it something
else but running with dream for
now then you get to put that through
your content filter so what kind of post
are you put in do they make me want to
dream a bigger dream what's on the
background
in your wall does it make me want to
dream a bigger dream what's your morning
routine does it make you want to dream a
bigger dream how do people leave you in
your coaching sessions When I visit your
website if you if you run the filter of
dream through everything that you make
and create it starts to change one how
you show up but then two how people talk
about you which then becomes your brand
rule number three is believe you talked
about the message yeah one message that
you could give in this part of your life
right now that you're experiencing to
your viewers what is that one message
that you give them it's still believe
you know like it's always believe it's
like it's like believe I
mean it's on the back believe believe I
think lack of belief is the world's
biggest problem you like we don't do
what we want to do or because we don't
believe that we can you know we don't
believe that we can we don't believe we
have the resources we don't believe
we're good enough we just don't believe
that it's possible for us we might think
oh it's possible for him or her but it's
not possible for me we just don't
believe and so um I'm I'm trying to make
content for the 19-year-old Evan who
didn't believe in himself but still now
like my my biggest problem now is I
don't believe in myself for the next
thing years yeah like the next big jump
what is that I don't know and a lot of
is I don't believe in myself enough to
even think about that or create that and
so it's a it's a NeverEnding Journey
which is you when you're talking about
growth you're never done growing you
keep climbing this is great saying
beyond the mountain is more Mountains
and so like you never actually want to
hit the top you know we've hit goals
before and then like oh that's it you
know you celebrate and then it kind of
feels over you always want a new
mountain to climb and so there's always
levels that you can climb and grow I
just try to take the approach and
something Denzel Washington said is that
every time you take a step up the ladder
of growth you reach back and help
somebody else get to level and so a lot
of times people are U have imposter
syndrome of I can't be like X it's like
well you don't have to be you just have
to if if that if Oprah is level a
thousand and you're level four most
people are stck at level zero so if
you're at four you can help them get to
step two and that's where most people
are still stuck um so yeah believe
believe it's possible believe you can do
it rule number four is develop a mindset
of Excellence Excellence is the pursuit
of perfection so we're never done what's
the perfect interview what's the perfect
question what's the perfect thumbnail
who's the perfect guest what's the like
you're never done it's it's never done
uh but that Pursuit is how we become
excellent what's a perfect workout
what's a perfect book again it's never
done but in the pursuit you become more
and more and more excellent and I think
you'll see that across High Achievers
nobody ever says they're done nobody
ever says this is it it's perfect like
there's always new things that you want
to add and tweak and change and people
to confer with and help um and always
new problems to go off and solve and so
it's it's getting dedicated to the
process um and that you're getting
better every day which is which is hard
because that means you're going to fail
and you're going to suck and you're
going to make mistakes and you won't
know uh until you get out there no
matter how much market research you do
you don't know till you start going off
and do it no matter what recipe you
follow or workout regimen you look at uh
you never know until you start go off
and do it and people get overwhelmed by
the option this is the problem you know
if back to the world you came from with
all of the fitness and diet and
everything else it's like okay I'm going
to you start with a goal of I want to
get into a healthy weight right I I want
to get down to my high school weight or
university weight or whatever and that's
a very clear tangible great goal like
let's get healthy but then how do you do
it do you go on the keto diet or the
carnivore diet or the vegetarian diet or
the vegan diet or the Mediterranean diet
and and are you fasting intermittent
fasting
water fasting coffee fasting you know
are you doing working out are you
crossfitting are you yoga are you doing
high intensity low int this like it's
just it's just this NeverEnding cycle of
more and more and more things to learn
where you will never learn everything
it's impossible to know everything and
so you need to just start and you learn
more in the process of doing then you
will just researching researching
researching and like planning to get a
plan uh and so that's what you find with
the at least that's what I found with
the world top Achievers is they have
this North Star that they're shooting
towards and that is a bold Noble
excellent even perfect goal and then how
you get there is super messy and very
chaotic and full of mistakes but they're
willing to go and make mistakes because
the goal itself is Noble also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is build
expertise how important is it then Evan
to have a niche and to be the expert in
one area versus trying to be the expert
in every
area I think you have to be an expert at
the thing that you love right and
so we all can wear multiple hats uh
ultimately I think your purpose comes
from your pain right I think like
whatever you struggled with the most is
the thing you want to help other people
through
so when you're in a when you're in a
room you have to figure out okay where
am I further ahead than these people
here and in some areas it may be lots of
things right it may be you know so I I'm
I was launching my new book when I went
there right if I'm in a room of people
who have never launched the book I can
give a lot of advice on how to launch a
book if I'm in a room with Brendan and
Dean and Russell and these guys they've
sold millions of books so like okay I'm
not you teach me what I'm doing wrong
like tell me where I'm screwing up in my
process um but I'm still happy to help
people with their books right I think
it's just as you scale up and get better
and better and better
um your ability to influence is going to
just keep improving so you know we're
we're all in this staircase of growth
and we never want it to end you want to
grow forever you don't want to stop
learning and every time you take another
step up you can reach back and help
somebody else up but you can only help
people to the step that you're
at you can't help
somebody get up
there so whatever you want to learn and
get better at keep improving and then
you can keep helping people along the
path you know the advice I'm trying to
give is is is difficult because it
depends on who you're talking to so the
last advice I gave about sharing your
message well maybe you're happy being
the Larry King like maybe that's your
goal maybe you don't have an opinion you
don't want to be I don't know what Larry
King stands for he's a great interviewer
he's had the best of the best he ask
great questions but I don't know when he
when he's taken a stance on something
maybe he has but it's just not what he's
known for if you're watching and you
want to be the Larry King of your Market
awesome like don't worry about creating
your own thought leadership content
um in terms of finding a
niche I look at I love helping people
believe in themselves right I mean I
have a I have a bigger YouTube audience
than any of the people who was at that
event but I'm focused on helping people
get to where I'm at and there's a lot of
people who are who I used to be right
there's a lot of people who are at the
beginning stages I'm not focused on like
the high high high high Achievers I
don't want to be Brendan Bard's high
performance coach right I'm okay with
that I don't want to be the niche guy at
the top I want to help the world right I
want to help everybody believe in
themselves more um so there just
different models like what do you
ultimately want to do what's your
mission and then making sure that your
actions will ultimately map to your
ambition because I think people look at
somebody else say oh I want that but
it's not actually what you
want so figuring out that first like do
you want to do you want to speak on
stage and have a huge audience do you
want to be a giant YouTuber and and have
millions of people watch your videos or
do you want to be a super select coach
that doesn't need to be a brand name but
you're you're you know how to do one
thing and and that's it and then you
you're like the elite player that people
are paying six figures a year just to
work with rule number six is create an
impact a lot of people quit so early on
their career and they never get the feel
the impact of cuz this is more
meaningful than a million views on a
video what does that mean where somebody
and all of us feel not just me like if
somebody came up to you and said hey
what you do touched me you know the art
that you made touched me inspired me
moved me and and the whole point of art
is to make people feel whether it's a
painting or a speech or a video or you
know beautiful design you know camera
it's like art makes people feel and so
we're all creators we're artists and so
when somebody comes up to you and says
hey your creation helped me feel
something Help Me Grow Help Me Grow help
me expand help me help me feel empowered
encouraged Unstoppable belief like
whatever even even if for like a moment
the fact that you made something that
then touch somebody else's life that's
why we do what we do like we all want to
wake up and feel like we're doing
something that matters and is Meaningful
having an impact so when somebody comes
and tells you that that's more the thing
that you'll hold on to and remember not
that I hit X number of views on a video
rule number seven is shift your
perspective what advice would you give
to those individuals that want to
develop that relationship to their
consumers their fan base yeah I mean I
think a lot of it I guess comes across a
strategy but it's more even the one I
just gave with my wife that's a strategy
he don't go to bed angry but it's more
like I can't go to bed angry because I'm
not gonna sleep right so it's not it's
not even a strategy it's more of a
necessity yeah yeah exactly so
so the short answer is just care right I
mean care about the people for me it's
always been about who is in front of me
instead of who's not as much as I want
to grow as much as I want to get to 10
million subscribers or a billion views
or whatever for the impact that it's
having it's still always about who I am
serving instead of who I'm not and I
think that's where most people make the
mistake is you look at your downloads
and then you look at Joe Rogan's
downloads you're like oh my God like I'm
nowhere close or your YouTube views
against mine or somebody else it's like
I suck I'm nowhere close um I did a I
have a movement makers program uh which
I train I do training twice a month to
help entrepreneurs build their movement
and today we were looking at people's
hundreds videos like their hundredth
video on YouTube so my 100th video had
like 190 views and three comments
my 100th video Gary Vee's 100th video
had 800 something views and three
comments a 100 videos in right and so
how do you keep going that's a 100
videos that's not like just four
episodes It's because 130 people or 190
people would ever watch that video
that's 190 people if you were gonna go
up and give a speech in front of 190
people You' be you'd be jazzed you'd be
excited you'd be scared you'd be nervous
like oh my God I want to let them down
people but because it's online like H
that sucks only 190 people compared to
all these other people so it's great to
want the growth it's great to strive to
improve and progress and get better and
and you always want to keep getting
better and the priority is the people
who currently are watching listening
because if you treat them great I mean
the strategy side is hey you treat them
great they'll tell more people they'll
come back you win for me it's just been
you're here I love you like let's make
this count whether it's you know that
where there whether you're the only
person who ever listens to this or
there's a million people end up
listening to it when I'm speaking in
front of 2,000 people it's great when
I'm speaking in front of four it's great
it gets to be more intimate and personal
right like I love you thank you for
being here thank you for giving me your
time and I hope to leave something with
you that helps you live a better life
right like it's that's the mindset
everything else follows the strategy
then follows right I'm struggling to
keep on top of everything like I can't
respond to every comment um I have
people on my team who help me with it
too but even on Instagram I'm still
trying to every new message that comes
in yesterday I was doing a whole bunch
of them at at you know 11:30 at night
hey thank you so much for that message I
really appreciate you thank you for
sharing my message with your audience
believe right that 8C clip because
somebody shared my story to their story
I don't know how I didn't even check how
many followers they had maybe it's three
and it's their mom and their sister and
their brother right great you shared
your story with your audience thank you
um I don't know I just I like it dude I
just like it I don't know that it's a
strategy for everybody so I think you
have to be that kind of person rule
number eight is help others why you
started your YouTube
channel uh I think your purpose comes
from your pain so I think whatever you
struggled with the most as a human is
what you want to help other people
through and so because I struggle so
much as an entrepreneur I try to make
content that I wish 19-year-old 11 could
have seen and I'm I'm what 13 years in
when did I start 2009 across all the
channels we probably recorded 15 20,000
videos like how do you keep gr how do
you not burn out how do you I I mean I
haven't missed an upload day in a decade
how well because you feel like what
you're doing matters and so I always
feel like the content I'm making is to
help even this interview like when you
she just pulled me aside you know we at
lunch I'm leaving she's like can I
interview you why because I'm hoping
that you know somebody watches this
video and maybe that makes a shift to
helping them believe a little bit more
themselves rule number nine is get
strategic what is your number one tip or
strategy to help us sell more understand
your most important
goal and then create the show that helps
you accomplish that goal like YouTube
can serve you in a lot of different ways
most people think of it just as a place
to be an influencer and build a brand
and and it is if you want long-term
success building a brand and having
people beat a path to your door is huge
but that doesn't happen in you know 30
days uh so if your number one goal is I
need to make sales in 30 days cool start
a YouTube show I run Business
Development let's go close I'm Number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is show up a lot of people
are too afraid to to share what the
truth is and it's easy to come with all
these reasons that are legit reasons but
the real answer is just like it's just
fear and that's okay and like even just
speaking it out loud about your
background now means the background has
less control over you you recognize how
ridiculous it is like okay now it's it's
I've voiced it it's it's kind of out of
my system H and it and it allows for
momentum to happen um an easy way around
it is uh videos have to get made and
this is what I tell myself it's like
videos have to get me would I love
everything to be in my office and
perfect sound and Perfect Light and
perfect everything of course but vide
still have to get made and so last month
I was on a cruise and I went to Alaska
and videos yeah so for my videos for my
main Channel with three point whatever
million subscribers I go out on my
balcony and I just take my phone out I
guess you can't see me gesturing but
just take my phone out and I I press
record and film videos from the balcony
uh because videos have to get out and so
that uh putting that in my calendar like
this you could have said no to this you
know if this wasn't in your calendar to
meet me you could have said I'm not
going to film today I'm not gonna go
live I'm not gonna I got my background
is all wrong right but it's in the
calendar and now you're you know I'm
gonna be going live by myself and like
where is she right so you have to show
up and so that's where you know the
commitment makes a difference and
especially if you're now going to commit
to coaching other people they're going
to show up you now have to show up even
if on the day
you don't like your background again you
still have to show up because they're in
your
calendar Evan I find you so interesting
because you're an introvert and and and
and generally speaking introverts get
energy for being alone that's kind of
like part of it um also call me out if
that's wrong but what's interesting is
you get a lot of energy from helping
people which usually in context is
around people yeah so it's just
interesting thing with you where it's
like you keep saying you're an introvert
but then when we were meeting you were
like pretty chill and laidback and then
the second that we started talking about
you like it's like you were taking the
energy yeah from the Environ so it was
just it's interesting I don't know that
I'll speak on behalf of all introverts
but you know my own story would be I
struggled with this a lot my biggest
fight with my agent was like you need to
be famous Evan it's like I don't want to
be famous why do I want to be famous I
don't want to be famous and he's like I
don't understand you everybody I work
with wants to be famous like okay cool I
don't know I don't want to be famous and
so we fought for years until he said you
don't understand you know the the if you
get more famous people hear the message
and it's always been about the message
and so hanging out in most like I
remember being in San Diego this still
happens this is like late last year a
couple months ago in San Diego uh Grant
Cardone was doing this event on in San
Diego and it was on a boat and the boat
was going to have like Tim TBO and like
all these CBS and and you went on a boat
cruise and you come back and because it
was like 3 or four hours on the boat and
I'd have no way to get back if I didn't
like it I didn't
go right it's like oh 3 hours on a boat
and I have no way to get back what if I
hate it right just like yeah I need an
escape plan I I got to go um but what I
realized was introverts love to serve
yeah like we want to serve too we want
to feel like the work we do has meaning
and matters to people and so that's what
I lean in and focus on and most
conversations do drain me if you want to
talk about the weather or I don't know
what do people talk about I I don't know
what people talk about I suck at all
that stuff I hate it it drains me like I
really I I do not like networking events
it drains me to no end I hate
introducing myself I hate asking
answering like well what do you do all
of that like I never talk to the person
on the airplane next to me yeah all of
it zero uh but if you can hit on like a
couple of if you're an entrepreneur or
you love salsa dancing or League of
Legends uh we could probably have like a
really deep 5 hour conversation
and so I think at least for me may not
for all introverts we love meaningful
deep powerful conversations and none of
the surface fluffy stuff and that's the
stuff that um really will drain me and
I'll avoid as much as possible yeah when
you think of an entrepreneur what do you
think if you were going to Mentor a
young person what do you think that the
one or two or three characteristics that
you'd really want to see in somebody is
before you said you know what yeah I
think they're going to they're going to
make it happen matter what I think
there's some characteristics to winning
so a lot of the ones you mentioned too
like persistence and dedication and hard
work it's like that is definitely needed
for entrepreneurs and they're just
characteristics of winning like you
could win and not be an entrepreneur and
have persistence and dedication and
faith and hard work I think to to
succeed as an entrepreneur you have
to want to make something different for
your life and for others because there's
there's always a path that's laid out
for you you know if you're talking to
kids like your parents have a have an
ideal plan for you they would love for
you to go and do blank and your school
and guidance counselors there's there's
these very easy laid out plans of what
you're supposed to
do you go to school and then you go to
college and then you get a job and or or
you don't go to college and you follow
in like family footsteps and whatever it
is but there's there's very easy paths
to follow for your career where being an
entrepreneur usually means you have to
step far outside those predetermined
paths for you and that's hard you know
when nobody in your family has done it
and when you don't have Role Models or
mentors or or you know people like you
to talk to that's really really hard to
step outside those predetermined paths
and that's what an entrepreneur is
willing to do is like not get stuck in
the grooves that have been laid out for
them when they're going to set a new
path for themselves it doesn't mean
they'll be super successful there's lots
of entrepreneurs who are below the
poverty line or like just making enough
money or it's just them and they're you
know they're just getting by like most
entrepreneurs are not Mega wealthy um
but they're doing it because they just
want to create their own path for
themselves and for the people around
them what advice would you give to that
person that's watching the show who's a
business owner that wants to start
content marketing posting on YouTube You
Know YouTube shorts Instagram stuff like
that I would again look at the first the
three shows that I talked about at the
beginning
most people when they're looking at
creating content they do the thought
leadership show which is the most
awkward show for people to do because
they struggle to talking into a camera
for most businesses if your business is
professional speaking then okay that's a
huge Advantage for you but for most
people they're not trained in how to
speak in front of a camera and so they
start making content and they suck and
it's true like you do suck but doesn't
mean you suck as a person it's just a
skill set that you have to develop to
continue to work on I usually need on
the first show which is the bis Dev show
even if this doesn't do well who are the
people that you want to build
relationships with that having them on
your show leads to referrals for your
company CU every company that's already
established knows the value of referrals
now let's increase our chance to get
more referrals and asking somebody to
come on your show is a lot easier than
asking somebody to Coffee to talk about
a potential you know partnership or
referral Arrangement right so it's about
relationships for someone who wants to
create this master morning routine you
know it's one thing to just listen or to
see what other people are doing but how
can they actually create one for
themselves so I I split it into two the
first part is what has made you bold
powerful confident alive right it it's
happened to you you've felt it it's just
not consistent that's the problem for
most of us it's not consistent you have
these moments of boldness like I can do
anything and then you wake up tomorrow
like I can't do that thing anymore and
we just live in the world of I can't do
it but you you feel like you're capable
of more but you're afraid to take action
so in those moments where you have felt
boldness what did you do just before
before did you did you have a
conversation did you meditate prayer
like whatever the thing was yeah then
that's not even pulling from somebody
else that's you you've already felt
boldness what happened how did you do it
now try to plan that in your morning
routine and that can be different for
other people for me it's helping people
and so the easiest way to do it is by
going live on Instagram um then it's
pulling from different people to see
what are they doing and how can you
apply it I love small tests yeah U we
were talking about journaling before
before went live um so people do
journaling Tim Ferris say journaling
like lots of successful entrepreneurs do
journaling so like okay I'm going to
great idea to action I'm huge on idea
you get an idea go do something about it
yes tell me about your daily
routine so I have a morning routine and
an evening routine that are fairly
consistent and then I have a daily
routine that's different than other days
so so one day a week to do different
things terms of that kind of daily
routine that switches
up um switching costs are real you know
even even in monotasking like we know
multitasking of of trying to do multiple
things at once but even monotasking to
do one thing at a time switching costs
are huge between jumping from one thing
to another so if I'm going to jump from
you to then going write my book to then
going and doing email to then go it's
just it's too much of a switch you know
for me to get into the zone of writing
my book I need 45 minutes just to get
back to where I was from the last time I
left off from it so I try to assign
different things for different days now
I'm I'm in complete control pretty much
of my calendar that may not be the case
for everybody but for what you can
control then being intentional about it
so for me Monte Monday is my mentoring
day we have 40 people on my team I want
to be the kind of boss that when they
come in we make them a better human than
if they ever leave right so I spend the
whole day mentoring the people on my
team Tuesday is my YouTube day it's
content day I'm filming like if you do
not have time in your calendar to film
you're not going to film you're not
going to make the content if you wait
till you're inspired you're never going
to make anything so Tuesday is like
YouTube it's consistent it's my calendar
every Tuesday I'm making content
Wednesday is my project day and that is
free it's open it's whatever I want to
work on because the over scheduled
entrepreneur usually ends up hating
their life or their business because
they never have time to work on the
things that that is new into their
company so my Tuesdays and Thursdays are
really jam-packed Wednesday in the
middle is completely open so yesterday
was a Wednesday I'm working on my book
next Wednesday I might work on something
completely different and it doesn't
always have to have a practical payoff
it's just something new fun exper
creativity is messy so Wednesday is a
messy day Thursday is my public facing
day interviews podcast today's a
Thursday when we're recording this right
that's right so when we book these you
know I 25 minutes on five minute break
25 minutes on five minute break so after
this I'm going into another 25 minute
session then the five minute break and
it's like my whole day gets filled up
doing other people's shows and podcasts
and it's it it's just staying in the
same energy like the energy you're
getting now I'm naturally introverted
and shy people don't get that about me
it doesn't come across but the energy
I'm showing up for your show is the
result of the five other shows I've done
before getting to you right and I'm
going to then take asish energy and pour
it into the next person right so this
you're you're not um sucking my energy
you're feeding me energy that I'm then
going to pour into the person who comes
afterwards right so like staying in that
energy zone is really important that's
how the day flies by and you get into
flow instead of having to jump from one
thing to the next Friday's my CEO day um
and I started with CEO hours like if I
had one hour what would I do if I was a
CEO like whatever that means to you
you're the CEO of your business now what
does that person do and I moved it to be
the whole day so like working on the
business instead of in the business uh
and then apply to the weekend like
Saturday's funay Saturday is fun stuff
to do with my wife with the family not
like we just got a new house and there's
insane amounts of work that has to get
done but that's not Saturday Saturday is
what we're going to do for fun new
restaurant Street Festival drive-in
movie theater hang out like whatever but
fun and then Sunday's family admin day
where that's
the getting ready
for Costco and doing the laundry and
whatever and then and then it repeats
again on Monday and like that your you
know your actions have to map to your
Ambitions you have you have goals of
what you want to accomplish and not just
like business goals but a life what do
you what do you want to what does your
dream life look like and then you have
to have it in your calendar to do the
actions otherwise it just becomes you
know a hope so that's my yeah that's my
I
love life design man it's all life
design and it'll change and switch right
it changes at the beginning I had nobody
on my team so I didn't have a a
mentoring day who was I mentoring nobody
so let get to work now I have 40 people
on my team so I need to have a day
focused on mentoring and so the
willingness this is like the willingness
to Pivot and change especially in
entrepreneurship because you learn and
grow right like entrepreneurship is a
greatest personal development course of
all time you're learning and growing and
improving so it's crazy to think that
how you start and what you're working on
now is still going to be the same thing
in 3 years like your business has to
Pivot and change and your calendar has
to Pivot and change as you change and
evolve as a human being so wherever I'm
not happy especially consistently like
if it's a couple days in a row of not
being happy something is wrong in my
calendar like I'm just not doing the
right things anymore and I need to make
a change and if you can catch it early
enough then you don't end up having this
giant crisis where you have to make this
insane change right because you feel you
just fell completely out of alignment
with yourself when you're having those
days what do you tell yourself or who
helps you on those days because we can't
all have 10 out of 10 days right like we
wish we could but they're not always
going to be a 10 out of 10 we have to
accept that sometimes there's a two out
of 10 or a four out of 10 what do you do
on those days yes
so my habits save me for most of most of
the time um I almost every day will have
a believe walk and and that's part of my
morning routine I wake up I get outside
I go for a beli walk and that's getting
fresh air but I'm also I'm also
listening to one of my own videos and
responding to people in my community to
remind me of the thing that I'm doing um
I haven't this part's a little weird
where like I haven't wanted to quit
people like what about quitting on you I
haven't thought about quitting ever on
YouTube uh it's too connected now to
like serving in what I do but do I have
days that are um lower energy or do I
have days where I'm not thinking big
enough oh I mean especially that one
100% you know um yeah I think I think if
you're consistently thinking about
quitting you have to you have to
understand the reason why is it because
you're afraid or is it because you don't
want to do things I think I think people
stay in things too long like when people
say don't quit don't quit I think people
should off often quit on businesses
sooner relationship sooner jobs sooner
because you'll never doing work that you
hate but if the reason that you're
quitting is because you're afraid that's
not a good enough reason um and so where
I am challenging myself to do the most
work is
on bigger thinking like the biggest
frustration for me is okay so if I'm at
three and a half million subscribers how
do I get to 35 right and how do I live
in that Vibe
consistently um if I'm feeling super low
energy I'll take a
break you know like I had people over at
my house not too long ago for my
birthday I've invested into a bunch of
different entrepreneurs and I Mentor
them once a week and they came over I
don't really celebrate my birthday so I
like okay come on over for my birthday
and and we'll hang out together and we
spent five days together and like all
day all night fell behind on like
everything I was doing and then I had uh
the Monday where like everybody went
home kind of Sunday night and uh like
okay I'm
I'm I'm not doing anything today you
know like my voice started to get a
little sore it wasn't as like it was so
much high energy I need to I need this
is today's recovery day I think I post
on Instagram like recovery day today
I'll see you tomorrow and I just checked
out of everything that I was doing we
have a big mission to change the world
right I'm and it's like okay immediate
goal I need and maybe we hit that in a
couple months it have to it doesn't have
to take the December to that's you're
going to leave but we can if you have 10
clients who we still we're happy too
right very much so but the immedate goal
is it's not some crazy thing that you're
coming in to say I need to have a thous
clients paying me right yeah so it's
five clients five clients between now
and DEC December right perfect at a
minimum so then it's who are the best
people who can afford you yeah to pay
$2,000 a month if you connect better
with women then we fine it's women it's
not that you only have to do one but
it's it's helpful to to yeah narrow in
on like the right influences to take you
to the path
so is it women in careers so I've
honestly mostly been I haven't coached
any woman been coaching men okay um and
it's been the people who I have been
coaching are people that are in the um
like in the fitness space so it's more
about figuring who are the people who
have budget who can hire you or you get
paid to come in to an organization and
help them with their
mhm yeah exactly honestly like as I
think more about this it's like how can
I create the Maximum Impact right not
yet okay no no this is where we get Stu
yeah exactly this is the Trap Maxim
impact doesn't make you money in the
next three years well that's true and we
need we have a drop dead date December
21st yes yes for sure you're right and
right so but that's not the question
right now Maximum Impact we just need
impact right Maximum Impact on like
individuals but not world oh yes high
impact and we need to be paid to do it
so we can continue to build in scale
okay I think people who are going to be
entrepreneurs is a really hard Market
because they just don't have yeah budget
right and especially if they quit their
job and then they go to start their
business then they have no more money to
pay you yeah so the coaching will
probably end absolutely so it's finding
people who are it could be if you're
making a quar million plus a year and
you want to start a business
yeah you know I'm I'm I'm going to help
you and I would get the 25k up
front once they start the business it's
going to be really hard to yeah right
and I collect after every session okay
yeah up front yeah like all of that it
could be potentially negotiable right
could I do quarterly installments could
I do just six months you don't have to
say no to it but you can say like here's
yeah here's here's what we did tell us
what is one thing you do every morning
to set your day up for
Success
um I've got a bunch I'm trying to think
like what would be a really cool or
different one
um thinking about service right like
it's so easy to get complacent as an
achiever so thinking about like what I
do today has to matter I want to create
something meaning
that's going to help impact other
people's lives today and putting that
pressure like tomorrow is a different
day today something important has to
happen giving has to be a part of the
morning routine
oh okay I'm GNA have to think about that
yeah whether that's whether that's
actually given in terms of like you're
going to take a call with somebody and
Mentor them uh or you're going to buy
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or you're just going to meditate
and pray for somebody like I'm thinking
of somebody in my head and I I want them
to have love today and you're like
focusing your energy on supporting
somebody else giving will make you feel
so much more alive and has to be a part
of your daily routine did you have that
experience that you had to go clean up
your network or your circle of friends
or yeah I mean one I'm introverted so I
don't have a lot of friends so that that
that uh you have a lot of wasn't a big
deal at the beginning but I think it it
for me it wasn't like there was this one
person or group of people who are really
negative around me it was more just a
slow letting go and spending less time
with people that then it kind of Fades
out so it wasn't an intentional you're a
negative person and I'm not going to
talk to you anymore it was just I'm I'm
moving in this direction and you're
moving in that direction and we just
don't have as much in common anymore and
so we just stop talking and stop hanging
out but it was never like this awkward
conversation of saying you're out of my
life and I think a lot of people stay in
relationships just out of convenience
and out of fear that just because you
went to grade four with them it doesn't
mean you still have to be friends with
them in your adult life you're probably
if you're watching the show Right
audience you're they're probably way
ahead of ahead of their friends already
they're the most ambitious people that
they know and if somebody is sucking
energy from you
you probably don't want to spend as much
time with them and if it's family it's a
little harder you don't want to
necessarily just cut off your mom from
your life although some people do that
because it's the best thing for them but
it could also be limiting access to
topics it's like okay we're not talking
about my career because every time we
talk about my career it goes down this
crazy negative path so we're not talking
about that but we're going to talk about
these things that we know we can connect
on because I love you right and so
limiting access or enough people I think
can be really helpful but it's just
paying attention to the energy that you
get from people right I'm you know I met
you earlier this
morning I'm I'm coming out of this right
we're going to have this interview I
already have more energy than when I
start right like we're going to leave
this and for me at least I'm going to
have more energy than when we started
right so when you're around the right
people it raises your energy absolutely
I totally agree with that and if I if
you're if I left an interview with
somebody and like I feel worse than I
did going in like okay I'm I'm not going
to talk to that person again yeah right
being dead and so it's a lot of energy
suckers or energy vampires or it's just
paying attention to that consistently
and if you find the awkward part is if
you find good people who you really like
try to spend more time with them and so
I have a saying that I like to collect
good people so somebody ask me what do
you collect I collect good peopleit
right I don't collect I don't collect
baseball cards or stamps or I collect
good people and it can be awkward
especially for introverts at the
beginning to like when you find somebody
at an event or on a call or somebody who
you don't really know very well but you
just had great energy that you leave and
you're like man that was awesome I I try
to find a way to spend more time with
that person whether it's just messaging
on Instagram with the start whether it's
trying to set up a coffee Mee and to
talk about our businesses like you be
the one to reach out cuz everybody knows
somebody in their Network who is a
positive optimistic energy giving person
you may not have a lot of those people
but there's one person you could think
of and it's probably not the closest
person to you it's probably a friend of
a friend or somebody you met at some
event but you can think of them find a
way to stay connected with them meet
them once a month for coffee connect
with them on Instagram and and go back
and forth just like have more of them in
your life and watch your life start to
Ripple forward in a positive direction
people are so scared of the opinions or
like I said they feel need they feel
they need to be somebody and it's so
powerful to where you know they aren't
open about it and it's it's it's when
you're open about it that things start
to open up for you so kind of like when
did you realize that dude many times and
and I'm still going through it just on
bigger levels I'm an introvert so that
doesn't come across in my videos and
interviews like this and stuff but but
I'm an introvert so I have no need to
share my story to talk the biggest fight
I get into with my agent who's this you
know tough New York guy is Evan you're
probably M you don't want to be famous
like yeah I don't I don't have a need to
be famous you need to get famous for
your message to get heard so how does an
introvert become famous I don't know I'm
trying to figure it out join me on this
journey and we'll see um Lots man Lots
uh from from big things to little things
let's start with a little one um I'm at
I'm at Tony robbins's event so Tony I've
been working with Tony for the past four
4ish
years he invites me to his event to sit
in his specific chairman you know
seating and meet them backstage and all
this stuff they have these security
guards who are all around the stage
because you can't get you know somebody
jumps on the stage they have to be there
so they're rotating right and so as they
rotate around every 20 minutes or so
they do a rotate and and the guy from
that corner comes to the front of the
stage and they they do this little fist
bump with each other and then and then
they rotate on to the next one so they
keep going in this clockwise Direction
every 20 minutes doing fist bumps so I'm
sitting there it's like it's happening
right in front of me because I'm in the
front row and uh I was like I'm gonna
fist bump the next security guard I'm
gonna fist bump I want to fist bump the
next security guard because just to show
some love to security guards you know
like hey you're important I recognize
you so the next rotation comes around my
heart's
beating so so they come and I put my
fist out like this he looks at it and
keeps walking like I just got I just got
owned I just got rejected by by the
security guard at Tony Robins vent I
can't believe it my initial instinct is
oh my God I hope nobody like who saw
that did anybody see me just get
destroyed here by the security guard and
of course we always make the story way
bigger in our head than than it is like
chances are almost nobody saw it and the
ones who did did they even care and I'm
sure like two people maybe saw it and
they're laughing great but in my head
it's like everybody the whole world saw
it right um and
so in that 20 minutes before the next
security guard fist bump came up I'm
sitting there I'm reflecting I'm not
even listening to Tony at this point
because I'm I'm stuck in my world about
the the Lost FB like what do I do next
and and here's the thing that got me to
do the fist bump again humans are built
to
serve humans are built to serve we're
wired to serve like serving and helping
others does the same thing to your brain
as food and sex like we're we're wired
to serve yep it's human nature it's
human nature it's human nature and at
the same time we
are afraid of of other people's opinions
judgments expectations and so most
people live life with their their foot
on the gas and the break at the same
time because serving involves other
people you have to help others you have
to do something for others it's not just
serving yourself that doesn't feel good
it's serving other people but if you're
also at the same time afraid of how
they're going to react and judge you
then you never do anything we could take
these businesses in different directions
like if the goal is is speaking the key
thing is getting to know the people who
are hosting these events who are the
people putting it on and building a
relationship with them the easiest way
to do that is the Bev show so you have
them on your show you already have a
podcast is great I don't know how you're
selecting the guests to come on your
show but now it's with an intent to I
want to get speaking gigs from this
person or their Network mhm like are you
already thinking about that or how have
you picked I mean the reason I started
the podcast was to have a big personal
development brand podcast and so my
concern in that is that a lot of the
people I get on now are speakers authors
you know coaches that stuff which I
understand I can't mark it to them
because they're in the same game but not
to dilute the podcast if that makes
sense so you have two choices there one
you start a different show geared just
towards this MH or two you find an angle
that it feels right your heart yeah to
have them on yeah so if you're looking
at who's putting on events for
entrepreneurs you can go research all
the events for entrepreneurs uh or even
like I don't know if you go into sales
or if you go into MLM yeah would yeah
great so all of those conferences or
people who are selling Insurance like
all of these things they're like pseudo
entrepreneurs insurance people are
you're kind of an entur there way less
risk yeah right yeah real estate same
thing you're an entrepreneur but there's
like a support system around it so
there's lots of events happen around
those things yeah you find a list of all
the events you find a list of who's
organizing them you invite them on your
show to be a guest they care about
personal development yeah otherwise it
wouldn't be putting on these events true
yeah why put on event for entrepreneurs
or real estate professionals or MLM
industry or whatever yeah they care
about this stuff do you personally
connect with them enough that it feels
right in your heart to have them on the
show you can make a judgment call yeah
whether it it's a fit for the main show
or you start a different show around it
but that's going to be your fastest path
to get speaking gigs right talk to the
people who are hosting the events yeah
other speakers and authors not that they
see you as competition yeah but they're
they're probably going to take the deals
that they like the best for sure you
know and they may not remember you were
pass like they have lots of entrepreneur
friends and speak your friends that you
may not be the first person that they
call yeah if they want to turn it down
that's right yeah right so it's not that
it's not possible it's just a much
longer road yeah so if we want to be
strategic and get we want to get deals
for our speaking gig like that's the
fastest way to do it yeah and it's not
that difficult to execute what are your
thoughts on the idea that maybe the the
lack of self-belief really is just the
problem is exposure for some people yeah
and and we're around people who keep us
stuck like your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are and the fortunate thing in you know
going 2023 2024 is you can change it
like you're the opportunities you have
right now at your age are so much better
than your parents at your age yeah like
we have the internet yeah we have
YouTube all the best mentors and
teachers are there like the information
now is available the opportunities are
available you had to be crazy if my I'm
42 years old if I look at my dad when he
was 42 he would have to be crazy to be
an entrepreneur you have to be basically
unemployable crazy to to start your own
company and and it was really hard now
anybody can do it so the world has
changed and so if you don't like the
environment that you're in and the
people and the voices that are in your
head cool you can shift it you can now
choose to be around more positivity and
and I encourage people to really do an
audit of the friends in your life the
people in your life and also who you're
following on Instagram on YouTube the
various platforms when you watch YouTube
videos or you're on Instagram and you
put it down do you feel better about
yourself or Worse do you spend spend two
hours just kind of mindlessly scrolling
cool like unfollow all those people yeah
because there's lots of like Instagram
and YouTube are not the problem there's
lots of great people posting amazing
content your life can change by being
around the right people so consciously
choose engineer who you're going to be
following and who you're G to listen to
doing the work is torture for most
people if you look at my channel we're
doing three videos a day for a lot of
people jumping into my work schedule
would be torture for them it would be
torture it's like it's just too much
work right and that's great and like I
love it though like I chose I chose this
life I love the work I'm doing I love
being here talking to dick you know this
is this is is good this is happy for me
other people like I got to talk to dick
I got to be on a a live stream I'm
panicking I'm freaking out you put me in
that landscaping job I had a landscaping
job I would die man like I hated that
job but for other people it's like you
know what I love being outside I love I
love being fit I love my friends here
like it's just to be successful in
anything you have to enjoy the work that
you're doing and not everything is great
you know not every day is roses you're G
to have a lot of crap that you deal with
and the thing that gets you through all
the crap is just the love for the
process and so I think it's still
important to have goals it's nice but
more important than the goal is the
journey to get there YouTube is a long
form platform this podcast however long
it goes it's not a it's not a 40c clip
right I love data I love making data
driven decisions it might be great to
feel a certain way but I want to see
that it actually has a result 100% my
morning conversation great my YouTube
YouTube gives you the best data of any
plat platform so when this video comes
out you'll see in your audience
retention there's a there's a curve
called the audience retention curve M
where basically you see where people are
leaving the video MH so at the start is
100% everybody who watches at 000000
they're they're there but then as the
video goes on it say curve you'll see at
some points a sharp curve where it drops
a lot people left whatever you did there
sucked don't do that again probably a
commercial you leave my commercials got
to pay the bills guys
but even even timing around the
commercials if you do it too soon you
might lose a big percentage of your
audience but there'll also be these
magical moments where it's flat which
means nobody left for this two-minute
clip nobody left whatever we were
talking about nobody left and then
you'll have some really magical moments
where it goes up how's that possible
people rewinding the clip to watch that
part
again that's what you cut and put your
Instagram can you talk a little bit
about the team and and how you feel
about creating a team around you and how
that works well teams are are critical
to grow and not everybody like most
small businesses are just a solo preneur
um but if you want to scale and grow
then you have to be able to work with a
team and you have to like managing
people a lot of people don't like
managing people they like just being by
themselves but if you want to get you
want to get a return out of it and you
want to have fun then you have to you
have to want to mentor and lead and grow
and learn to AG a team I think I think
you've got to First be connected like
for you you might not love digging
ditches uh but you got to connect to the
mission of like hey then this is for
somebody this is for somebody's home
this is we're making people healthier
we're we're helping people's lives like
you have to connect to why you're doing
the work if you don't enjoy the actual
like digging ditches or you connect to
like hey this is a good workout and I'm
getting some vitamin D while we're doing
this yeah right exactly but but a lot of
people have a hard time moving from
digging ditches to then being the person
who manages 50 people who are digging
ditches and you have to love people
training them you have to love mentoring
them like even you going and
volunteering to talk to the Junior
Achievement kids speaks to your
willingness to mentor and train and
guide and and just try to give back
right that's what you have to be doing
for your team you're basically a little
further ahead than them and you become
an almost Father Figure or or uncle or
older brother depending on the age gap
between people on your team to help them
become better humans you know the goal
is they become better humans when
they're with you they're not just
collecting a paycheck I think if we look
at Instagram for example it's a lot of
people sharing all of their best moments
it's their highlight reel of their life
and all these awards that you won and
the Beautiful Photoshop Beach picture
and all that and I think there's still
definitely a lot of that and a lot of
people who are too afraid to ever show
any kind of weakness um even some people
in the personal development space are
like too afraid to show their weakness
uh and then some people are very candid
and upfront and share everything and
that becomes their brand um you know if
you look at Gary he's he's very open
about how he struggles with candid uh
being candid having candid conversations
um Mel Robbins is very open to sharing
like her brand of personal development
is basically all the stuff that she's
trying to figure out for herself yeah
she says and then she she learns and
then she teaches uh so I think you know
authenticity is a big word people are
thrown around I think it can definitely
help connect people to you I think it
just depends on who you're following um
there's a lot of people who who come off
as perfect still and they they grow
their following doing that and there's a
lot of people who lean into the other
side and show all the the warts and um
that attracts people as well I love that
showing all the warts showing all the
warts and and you get to decide who you
want to be right I think ultimately
you'll be happier if you show the warts
and the what you're insecure about and
like James aler friend of the channel um
he likes to say for his podcast that he
basically thinks about what's the what's
the problem that he's most embarrassed
about right now that like someone like
him should have figured out and then
tell people about
it like what are you struggling with
right now that you should have already
figured out by now and then and then
tell people uh and and that makes him
very endearing and that's why a lot of
people love him what your current
morning routine looks like so I go
through five S's
uh sing Sun sore sweat scare so sing I
put on music right away and any song
that will get you like if it came on
you'd have to bounce and you'd have to
sing right yeah um so right now there's
a there's a Chinese rap that I did it's
a Chinese song that I did a rap in
English on top of yeah and so I play
that every morning um Chinese rap is
like dance or is it like straight up
like hardcore rap uh I'm rapping yeah to
a Chinese song so it's this woman who's
rapping and I sped her up and then I'm
rapping over the parts where she's not
singing that was a fun little project
that I worked on um so I like it it
makes me move so I I'm rapping to my own
song every morning while it comes on but
whatever song gets you up and ready to
go cuz we wake up and you know you're
tired and starting your day and so music
is the fastest way to change your state
like as soon as it comes on in 5 seconds
you can already be feeling better right
oh yeah and there's no one Magical song
it's whatever is for you and the
audience um then Sun so I like to get
outside so we got two dogs are in here
with us today I like to get outside
outside just to get some fresh air on my
face we're in Toronto it's December
there's not a lot of sun happening right
now but just just getting out of your
environment even if you work from home
the the walk from just your bedroom to
the office you can carry with that still
the tired energy of the bedroom right so
get outside get some fresh air even if
it's um just go out on the balcony and
just Tak in some sun for a little bit
bit mother nature mother nature makes a
difference um then soar so this is the
most important part what is the thing
that you need to do every day that makes
you feel bold powerful Unstoppable
confident alive whatever that thing is
do it first thing in the morning instead
of waiting like maybe it's listening to
the PVE your Paradise podcast or
watching the video series now it's
happening if that's a thing then then
you watch it every morning you listen to
it every morning um most of us don't
have enough intention behind the day
yeah and so I know it's part of what you
in the morning too but for me it's uh I
go live on Instagram so service if I
feel like the work that I'm doing
matters is important I'm serving
somebody it it makes me more amped up
for the day totally so I'll go live on
Instagram every morning and people join
in from around the world asking
questions and I help them and quick half
hour um and that's what I need to do so
other people maybe it's meditation maybe
it's prayer maybe it's something like
anything whatever the thing is that
makes you feel bold powerful confident
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel bold and Powerful
your your year is going to look totally
different like where you are in one year
will be totally different than where you
are right now amen um and then the last
two are just sweat and scare so I'll do
a workout and then hop into a cold
shower cuz like what do you like to do
for working out um usually do 100
push-ups 100 squats what am I doing now
100 push-ups 100 squats and 100 jumping
jacks yeah and then you do like the Wim
Hof the whole like cold hot that's it uh
not hot just cold just cold just cold
yeah there's no hot in the Wim office no
no I mean like the cold like the whole
the the Heat and coolness like you get
really worked out like sweaty and then
you do the cold then jump into the cold
yeah when did you start the habit of
replacing those negative thoughts with
positive ones and then when did you
start to see them take root and actually
manifest in your life I don't know that
I made a conscious choice that like now
I'm going to replace this thought with
this thought I think it's just as a
result of being in the industry so long
watching in so many like if you think
about what I do and how many videos I
watch of how many successful people they
all have some core themed to them and
whether it's entrepreneurs or athletes
or artists or musicians or whoever they
have similar themes and and you know
turning lemonade or turning lemons into
lemonade you know turning a negative
into a positive is is a consistent theme
across everybody and so I think it just
it happened subconsciously just by being
in the environment of having those
people around me virtually to the point
where I was doing that exercise being
forced to sit with negative thoughts and
it it I had changed but I didn't notice
like I don't there was no moment of
coming out of the Cocoon and now I'm a
butterfly just slowly became here I am
as a butterfly gotcha so it was just
going through the process yeah it's it's
like imagine if you were working out
your legs every day you don't you don't
you don't see a daytoday difference
there's no one moment like oh you did
one extra hard set and now you've got
these Rippling calves ready to go right
but I think the only difference was I
wasn't
even consciously training it was just
because it was in my environment and I
think that happens for a lot I think
that happens for most people just in a
negative way you're constantly watching
news and Twitter streams and all of this
negativity and all of a sudden you know
you start to become a negative person
because of all the things that are
happening around you but it's not that
you can pinpoint one thing that that was
the moment you became negative or even
notice that you're becoming negative
It's Just Happening yeah and so that's
the power of when you shift your
environment and you're controlling what
you're consuming into your you know into
your brain so I was conscious what I was
consuming I wasn't conscious about a lot
of the transformation that happened as a
result it's only in looking back or
doing exercises like that um that I
notice the difference I mentioned grief
as a caveat because that's the only one
that I don't think you can you can just
positive your way out of sure you know
like I think you just have to feel your
way through grief at least me you know I
have I haven't lost my parents so that's
awesome but um my family dog was like
that was the only time I haven't made
videos in the past 10 years is when my
family dog passed away wow uh because he
died on filming day and I just couldn't
film and I I could have if it was
anything else if I was jealous if it was
angry if I got cut off on traffic if I
lost a bunch of subscribers I don't know
something else happened like okay come
on let's go car like film but I just
didn't feel right to push past it to
film you know like I film with a
concussion and a broken neck and all
this other stuff but when when Toby
passed like I don't know it doesn't feel
right to just brush it away and so I
just have to feel
this because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to see 10 more amazing rules for me
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there and so I just
want to try to make the road a little
bit easier for other entrepreneurs to
not have to struggle as much as I did
there's so many great causes in the
world but what's the one that you're
going to want to commit to well it's the
one that you feel most connected to you
don't care about entrepreneurs and